and impeach Trump rally in Washington DC
draws a record crowd of zero people
Democratic presidential frontrunner Joe
Biden collapses in early primary polls
we examine what that means for the
cannon at the party in 2020 then another
Democratic candidate Tulsi Gabbard gets
woke on borders and late-term abortion
and finally the New York Times gives us
the single dumbest article on the
Internet today and there was a lot of
competition all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today on this
overarching topic of the Democrats who
cried wolf of what it seems to be from
the presidential race to the impeach
Trump movement to the mainstream media
the Democratic base just seems to be
tired of being lied to so we'll get to
that in a second first though we got
some breaking news that just came out
president Trump has fired his national
security advisor John Bolton he released
the news on Twitter of course where else
would he release it and a president
Trump tweeted a quote I informed John
Bolton last night that his services are
no longer needed at the White House I
disagreed strongly with many of his
suggestions as did others in the
administration and therefore I asked
John for his resignation which was given
to me this morning I thank John very
much for his service I will be naming a
new national security adviser next week
this is a bad move for the
administration this is really bad news
I'm it's too bad John Bolton was one of
the sharpest people in the White House
with the greatest grasp on international
politics he was despised by the left and
many people on the right which is how
you know that he had done a pretty good
job I would imagine the timing of this
firing has something to do with the
Taliban dust-up there was going to be
this Taliban meeting secret negotiations
at Camp David and it looked like the
State Department under Mike Pompeo was
pushing for that looked like John Bolton
as a national security adviser was
pushing against that then the meeting
was put off looks like John Bolton won
that battle but he may have the loss the
war because he is out it was always a
little bit of a strange move for John
Bolton to be picked as the national
security adviser to President Trump and
the reason for this is that President
from ran in 2016 essentially as a dove
he you know he did say he wanted to
destroy Isis so he had a little bit of
that hawkish rhetoric but broadly he was
an anti-war candidate and John Bolton
has always favored a more aggressive
foreign policy I think he wrote an op-ed
in The New York Times when the Iran deal
was being discussed that said something
to the effect of too
stop Iran's bomb bomb Iran so it always
seemed like a little bit of a strange
match but I was glad that he was in the
administration just because he's super
smart
even if Moulton was an odd choice it was
healthy for Trump to have him there
because it gave some balance to the
White House and because the guy is just
so sharp and so experienced but uh I
guess when I saw this news on Twitter it
occurred to me that today is just gonna
be defend john bolton against specie as
a tax day because there is a popular
narrative on the right that john bolton
is basically bill kristol with a
mustache or that john bolton is a neocon
war monger or the john bolton is some
awful terrible person and it's it's just
ridiculous that john bolton one of the
lines that he brings up a lot in
politics is that politics has
complicated geopolitics is complicated
and to try to put him in one of these
little categories as neocon or paleo con
or something is ridiculous he isn't in
in any way easily categorized because
he's a in advanced and sophisticated in
mind the one way i think you could
describe john Bolton's view of the world
is to put american interests first I
mean you could describe him as an
American first thinker and when John
Bolton was the ambassador of the United
Nations this was very clear he was not
confirmed they had that President Bush
had to appoint John Bolton as a recess
appointment and earlier when when
ambassador Bolton I guess is now how you
would now refer to him earlier when
ambassador Bolton was speaking to the UN
he made very clear his view of America's
role in the world and it was a view that
I think most Trump supporters would
agree with which is that there is no
such thing as the United Nations there
is the interest of the United States
which may or may not coincide with the
Preferences of the international
community but regardless of what all
those other countries want the US will
pursue her national interest that I want
to leave with you in this very brief
presentation is where I started is there
No United Nations there is an
international community that
occasionally can be led by the only real
power left in the world and that's the
United States when it suits our interest
and when we can get others to go along
the precariat Building in New York has
38 stories if you lost 10 stories today
it would make a bit of difference this
kind of mindless creation of the United
Nations as something different than what
it's in the United States interest to do
isn't going to sell here or anywhere
else
the only question only question the
United States is what can our national
interest and if you don't like that I'm
sorry but that is the fact love that guy
the only way that I'll be ok with him
leaving is NSA's if they put him up to
be the UN Ambassador again that's that's
my view on John Bolton but today's show
is not about the Trump administration
it's about the alternative it's about
how the left seems to be collapsing and
it seems to be collapsing rather quickly
all at once what's going on we'll get to
it in a second but first I've got to
thank our friends over at expressvpn
this topic is now more important now
more than ever because everybody wants
your data you can't trust certain
elements in Silicon Valley to treat
conservatives fairly but if you can't do
that then how can you trust them to
handle your privacy and personal online
data that is why I strongly recommend
using expressvpn every time you go
online I know what you're thinking I
used to think it too Oh nobody wants my
data now me they don't care what I'm
looking at no no they don't that's okay
bs big tech companies can use your IP
address to match your internet activity
to your identity or your location and if
you aren't listening to this show
something tells me you look at some
pretty weird stuff online okay I know
what you do you go into that incognito
tab and then you start looking at all
those seedy websites like daily wire
comm when I use expressvpn search
engines and media sites can't see my IP
address at all my identity is masked and
anonymous expressvpn has the added
benefit of encrypting one
percent of your data to keep you safe
from people who you don't want to have
your data at guys just do it right now
one tap of a button and you are
protected make sure that you protect
your data because there's a lot of stuff
on there that you do not want getting
out to other people especially people
who are not friendly to your political
points of view or not friendly to you
period expressvpn as the answer protects
your online activity today with the VPM
that I trust to keep my data safe visit
expressvpn comm slash michael to claim
an exclusive offer for my listeners that
is expr ESS VPN comm / michael li CH AE
l for three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn VPN dot-com
slash Michael to get started today's
shows not about the Trump administration
with plenty of time to talk about the
Trump administration it's about the
alternative because when I look around
not just the rank-and-file left not just
the presidential candidates not just the
mainstream media I see it all collapsing
at once you know like Ernest Hemingway
said it's gradually then suddenly there
was an impeach Trump event yesterday in
DC or at least there was supposed to be
an impeach Trump event yesterday in DC
it was going to be outside of the
capital where all the lawmakers are
gonna gather because Congress is back in
session and they wanted to send a
message to impeach President Trump this
was supported by some of the biggest
organizations on the left by indivisible
by moveon.org I've need to impeach stand
up America March of truth by the people
common cause free speech for people
democracy for America how many of these
organizations do these people have
progressive democrats of america credo
and democrats calm here's what the
website read in advance of this event
quote the president vice-president and
all civil officers of the United States
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for and conviction of
treason by bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors the charge of high
crimes and misdemeanors covers
allegations of misconduct by officials
such as purge
both abuse of authority bribery
intimidation misuse of assets failure to
supervise dereliction of duty they go on
all these awful terrible things that
Trump is alleged to have done there was
just one problem with their of them
nobody showed up nobody showed up zero
people this was a big event that had
been promoted by a lot of very big
groups why did nobody show up you know
Breitbart was the one who figured out
that this event was a total flop and
then the reporters at Breitbart reached
out to some of the people who were
putting it together no response and then
immediately after this was reported on
the website took down the event they
just they wanted to forget about it why
did nobody show up to this event is it
because all of a sudden everybody loves
Trump I don't think so
is it because nobody in the country
wants to impeach Trump no I don't think
so I think it's because even leftists
are tired of being taken for suckers and
they're tired of being taken for suckers
by their own alleged leaders you know
the left has cried wolf for three years
more than three years this is the result
of that the left put all their eggs in
one basket and that basket was the
Russia collusion narrative we're gonna
limp each Trump because he's a traitor
because he colluded with Russia because
and it just didn't happen so then it was
stormy Daniels Trump slept with a porn
star and paid and we're gonna take Trump
down for that then it was his finances
then they was back to Russia again and
then it was racism then he called
neo-nazis very fine people except then
you look at the tape and he didn't call
neo-nazis very fine people he explicitly
condemn them and then and then and then
and then there was never any argument
for impeachment and the left knows this
and the rank-and-file knows this and
they're sick of it look it's not that
the left doesn't want to impeach Trump
it's just you know you
gotta put on your pants in the morning
you gotta walk out the door you got to
take the bus you got to go over to the
Capitol you got to hold up the sides and
Beach Trump and they don't believe it
anymore because it's not gonna happen it
is not gonna happen the anti-trump
rhetoric from the mainstream media and
Democratic candidates is still in a
fever pitch but it doesn't correspond to
reality compare the resistance the Trump
resistance to the Tea Party think about
these two things tea party 2010 even a
little bit before that totally
legitimate movement rose up in
opposition to a massively unpopular law
called Obamacare that tried to take over
1/6 of the economy that took away
Americans doctors that made prices go up
maybe the quality of care decrease that
unconstitutionally forced Americans to
buy a private product from the federal
level also the tea party was running
against a terrible economy Barack Obama
comes in in a recession sure but then
because of his awful economic policies
there was no recovery slowest recovery
in history they also on in the Tea Party
were running against a very unpopular
corporate bailout so the big banks I
mean there was there were several
bailouts but there was the bailout of
the banks so then there was the
unpopular stimulus plan the banks in
part get us into this mess and then what
do we do the federal government uses our
tax dollars to bail them out the there
was this slush fund stimulus package
that didn't bring with it any jobs they
also were running against expanded wars
in the Middle East Barack Obama expanded
wars in the Middle East
almost immediately after he got elected
and what did the tea party do they had
these legitimate grievances they were
very specific they were very particular
they organized they rally their
candidates they won 1000 seats around
the country that's impressive and and
the thing I always noticed about Tea
Party rallies I went to a number of them
that you know all the campaign's I was
working on campaigns at the time they
would all stop by these Tea Party
rallies the tea party they'd show up and
and they leave their rallies and the
place looks cleaner than it did before
they got there you know they were very
well behaved say whatever you will about
the ideology of the Tea Party
Jenning was really positive for the
country but they were well-behaved there
were serious people compare that to the
resistance the resistance is a bunch of
aggrieved ex-hippies and blue haired
feminists who don't like Trump's me and
tweets that's it what are they running
against are they running against some
unpopular law
what's the unpopular law tax cuts yeah
we need to sweep the country because
Trump let us keep more of our money I
don't think so
is it the economy now the economy is
doing great is it
wars in the Middle East if anything
President Trump has curtailed wars in
the Middle East they're not running
against anything real it's not even that
the left doesn't want to impeach Trump
anymore it's just that many of them are
very tired of having their time wasted
and you see this in the presidential
polls you know you see this the
Democratic frontrunner right now is
collapsing terrible polls coming out for
Joe Biden out of Iowa and New Hampshire
must win early primary states we'll get
to that one second but first two or
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 that's the bad news the good
news is with today's advancements in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss let me tell you guys look at me I'm
not like the biggest Adonis in the world
okay I'm not the biggest athlete I was
not the captain of the football team but
I always did pretty well with the ladies
how cuz I got you know pretty solid had
a hair over here keeps has
revolutionized the way that men are
treated for hair loss you used to have
to go to the doctor's office for your
hair loss prescription now thanks to
keeps you can visit a doctor online and
get medication delivered to your home no
more waiting rooms no more pharmacy
checkout lines get doctor attention and
discreet drug delivery all from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
prevention is the key here you can do it
keeps treatments really work they are up
to 90 percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss but the
sooner you start using keeps the more
hair you will save you've got to act
fast you've got to act now many men will
experience hair regrowth even with keeps
treatments it's really
working guys it's it's the same thing I
talk about this so much especially for
guys we just get a little task lazy you
know we just get a little we don't we
don't want to take the five minutes to
go and take some action this can really
change your life if you are ready to
take action to prevent hair loss go to
keeps calm slash Knowles kena wles to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that is K EEP s.com slash
Knowles bad news for Joe Biden
Democratic frontrunner according to new
CBS YouGov polls out of Iowa and New
Hampshire early primary States Biden's
lead has all but vanished this is the
new poll by 29 percent in Iowa you know
where Bernie Sanders is number 226
percent three percent larger difference
that is nothing that is zero how about
Elizabeth Warren she's down there at 17
percent New Hampshire Warren is actually
leading now 27 percent Biden is in
second place in New Hampshire 26 percent
Bernie at 25 so it's more or less a
three-way tie Nevada at least binds
gonna win Nevada right no Sanders is up
29 Biden is second at 27 Warren is down
there at 18 only in South Carolina does
Biden have a commanding lead 43 %
Sanders is 18 Warren has 14 and why is
that the reason this is still the one
good news for Biden is that the other
candidates have very little black
support Democratic Party you need black
support to win Biden still has black
support there are more black voters in
South Carolina so he's doing better the
bad news for Biden is that Democrats are
now rejecting the electability argument
there clearly rejecting him Biden's only
pitch is a vote for me I'm the best guy
to beat Trump why am I the best got to
beat Trump is it because my policies are
the most exciting no is it cuz my
policies are the most popular no it's
because I've accomplished the most no
it's because I'm the most electable okay
the minute that you fall down in the
polls the minute you lose Iowa you're no
longer the most electable the minute you
lose Iowa New Hampshire you're
definitely not the most alike
it is a house of cards that the Joe
Biden is standing on right now I think
it is the same reason I think basically
Democrats are sick the Democratic base
the left-wing base they're sick of being
played for suckers could you imagine
being told Joe Biden is the most
electable Joe Biden ran for president in
88 didn't get anywhere because he lied
and plagiarized then he ran in 2008
didn't get anywhere because he's nobody
because he's nothing and now you're
gonna say after two different times in
the 80s in the 2000s now 10 years later
all of a sudden Joe Biden is the most
electable candidate people aren't gonna
believe that you can't you can't just
keep lying to them all the time same
thing not just in a presidential race
this is true at the governorís level
this is true at the Senate level Stacy
Abrams do you remember Stacy Abrams
Stacy a nervous ran for governor of
Georgia she was like a representative in
the Georgia House of Representatives
Stacey Abrams runs for governor of
Georgia against Brian Kemp and she loses
in 2018
she didn't even lose by a little it's
not like it was at 300 votes that
separated him
she lost fifty point two to forty eight
point eight so you know close election
but not that close
didn't even trigger an automatic recount
if it had been closer would have got an
automatic recount she was trying to get
recounts to get to the automatic recount
then after it became clear that she lost
she wouldn't concede she still hasn't
really conceded she still pretends that
the election was stolen from her
unfairly now she's coming out with a new
book I kid you not
Stacey Abrams Georgia House of
Representatives failed candidate for
governor this is her new book the Abrams
playbook the strategy and path to
victory in 2020
she better lawyer up because I am going
to sue Stacey Abrams for plagiarism
because I suspect that the content in
her book is exactly the same as the
content in my best-selling blank book
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide Stacey the Abrams
playbook the strategy and path to
victory in 2020 the OJ Simms
in playbook the strategy and path to a
happy marriage absolutely absurd she
lost she lost but every single time the
Democrats go all-in she didn't really
lose Stacey this is it okay we lost this
race we lost that race we lost 2016 we
lost this one after that this one after
that this would have been Abrams she's
gonna be the one put all your money here
donate all your money here go out there
This Is It this is the turning point in
America and then she loses but they
can't admit defeat they can't admit that
they fail so say no she didn't really
lose the the base is tired of being lied
to
the Republican base gets tired of being
lied to sometimes I think that was a lot
of the frustration that led to President
Trump is at least Trump offered
something different he offered different
policy proposals no matter what other
people tell you other people say Trump
only got elected because you know he
made jokes on the campaign trail
president Trump offered actually
different policies than other candidates
in that race and that other candidates
in recent memory and they went for him
because people on both sides of the
aisle are tired of being lied to and
speaking of Georgia Democrats now have a
new Senate candidate in Georgia and
second verse is the same as the first
the guy who was running for Senate and
georgina see if you remember this name
John Asaf do you remember that name I do
I miss John aasif because John Asaf in
2017
he was the Democrats it boy he was
stacey abrams before stacey abrams he
was bado o'rourke before bay know our
work john asif was the guy he was
running in Georgia's 6th congressional
district I think which had been Tom
prices see Tom price had left it to go
serve as HHS secretary before that it
was Newt Gingrich as seat this was a hot
seat Democrats run this nobody pretty
boy named John Asaf for six months Assaf
was the biggest name in town the race
ends up being the most expensive house
race in US history costs 55 million
dollars
Democrats put all your money here here's
how you're gonna win this is it this is
the referendum on Trump sure we lost in
2016 but now the first election after
that we're gonna win this and except
they accept he lost he lost it was not
the beginning of the resistance he lost
so now what he lost what's gonna happen
he's gonna run again of course and this
time he's running for Senate this time
it'll be different guys this is bado or
work syndrome this is Democrats failing
up this is Democrats relieving
themselves on your thigh and telling you
that it's raining remember beta was
going to be the next big thing dumped
all that money into Texas and then he's
not then he loses bado loses his Senate
race in Texas so he runs for president
John Asaf loses his house race in
Georgia so he runs for the Senate they
want their candidates to fail up and the
whole Assaf campaign was a dishonest
even right down to his engagement John
Asaf this is kind of weird single
nothing guy and so as he's running he
decides he's gonna get engaged to his
longtime girlfriend okay that's good I
was two years ago guys still not married
it was all just a farce it was all just
a fake he's just a total empty suit even
that part of it was a sham and the
Democrats to their credit are tired of
being lied to you see this with one of
their presidential candidates actually
Tulsi Gabbard who is now being kept out
of the next democratic debate is
basically saying enough is enough she is
the one Democratic candidate to come out
and start challenging Democratic leftist
radical 20-19 orthodoxy we'll get to
that in one second but first I have to
thank our friends over at paint your
life I love this product if you want to
give a truly meaningful gift you have
got to try paint your life calm paint
your life is incredible you can have an
original painting of yourself your
children your family a special place or
a cherished pet done for you at a price
that you can afford from paint your life
calm I was very skeptical with this when
I first heard about paint your life I
said there's no way it says there's no
way I'm gonna get a real painting a real
true painting done by hand world-class
artist
from a photo you do it's a real painting
I got mine it was an oil painting makes
the perfect gift so I said okay my
step-brother got married I was the best
man in the wedding so one of the gifts I
got him is this really nice it was a
photo from Grand Central of him and his
bride and I sent to Dan and I said okay
do a painting out of this I was floored
with how incredible this painting looks
it is unbelievable
he was floored she was floored I am
using them again I'm paying more money
commissioning more art it's just amazing
and you work with him throughout the
whole process of the send you proofs
every detail will be perfect because you
will be seeing it and all these
different steps of the way there is no
risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded great
for decor it is an actual work of art
it's just it's just an amazing service
with paint your life you get your
favorite memories transform into a work
of art that will be cherished forever
truly special gift for someone you love
or for yourself get it today it is right
now for a limited time you'll get 30%
off your painting 30% off your painting
and free shipping to get this offer
right now stop what you're doing text
Knowles Kanda wles
2 for 8 for 8 for 8 that is Noel's two
four eight four eight four eight text
can or wles - 48 48 48 message and data
rates may apply
we've got a lot morning in - we got to
get to woke tulsi gabbard we have got to
get to the dumbest article on the
internet today we have so much more but
you got to go to daily wire.com to do it
you get me you get the Andrew Klavan
show you get the mention Bureau show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
which is coming up on Thursday by the
way you get another Kingdom which is
we've started recording season 3 it's
super fun and you get the leftist ears
tumblr which is so important you know
from you can probably hear I'm a little
under the weather today I have a little
stuffy so some people like to make a hot
toddy I love a good hot toddy you put a
little bourbon in there you put a little
honey put some lemon the key is the
saline solution the greatest saline
solution of course are left as tears go
to daily we're calm we'll be right back
with a lot more
all right so we have got to get to woke
Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi Gabbard you'll
remember she is I think wanted for
murdering Camilla Harris during that
presidential debate a few weeks ago she
came out and just absolutely went for
the jugular on Camilla's career and
Tulsi I think probably as a result of
that is being kept out of the Democratic
debates she's probably the most
interesting candidate left party right
now very dovish on foreign policy and
nearly isolationist you might say though
she has military service herself so
she's got some sort of personal
credibility she went on Dave Rubens show
as far as I can tell the only Democratic
candidate to do that Andrew yangdon as
well and Tulsi goes on Dave Rubens show
she finally unlike every other Canada on
that stage decided to break from the
radical increasingly radical leftist
orthodoxy actually a few different
issues beginning even with the central
anti Trump democratic issue open borders
she you know we've heard now from a lot
of people on the left they'll say open
borders isn't real it's a Republican
talking point it's propaganda nobody
really is calling for open borders and
of course they are I mean they're
they're openly calling for the
decriminalization of border crossings
they're calling for massive amnesty
they're calling to halt deportation
they're calling to abolish immigration
and customs enforcement there they are
certainly calling for open wars but so
far the Democratic Party has been in
lockstep denying this Tulsi Gabbard
comes right out on the Rubin Show and
admits the Democrats are for open
borders and she's not I don't I don't
support open borders without secure
borders we don't really have a country
and while some of the other Democratic
Canas will say we'll open borders that's
a conservative argument and that's not
really what's being advocated for if you
look at the practical implications if
some of the things are pushing for it is
essentially open borders absolutely
right
by the way just as a practical note to
the other Democratic candidates we're
not talking about John Hickenlooper
we're
talking about Tim Ryan we're not talking
about Eric's wall well I think he's out
of the race we're not talking about jay
inslee we're not talking about I don't
Amy Klobuchar we're just not talking
about these people because they're not
serious candidates we are talking about
Tulsi Gabbard who's also polling very
low why because while all of those other
candidates are trying to be the poor
man's Joe Biden or the poor man's Liz
Warren or the poor man's Kamala Harris
Tulsi Gabbard is her own woman she is
her own candidate I don't agree with her
on most things but at least she's
offering something different she's she's
actually giving voters a choice not an
echo what the conservative activist
Phyllis Schlafly talked about at the
beginning of the post-war conservative
movement Tulsi gabbard's offering
something different and I think it makes
her much more interesting I think it's
it's her best shot I think a lot of
these other candidates should try to
break lockstep if they want to break out
as well and until see Gabbard didn't
just touch open borders which is a major
Democratic issue of third rail you know
at least on the Left you can't touch it
or you'll you'll lap yourself she even
went after abortion at a time when the
left is moving dramatically into not
just they support abortion or late term
abortion or abortion at the point of
birth or post birth abortion in the case
of Ralph Northam governor of Virginia
abortionist babies are being born if you
look at Andy Cuomo governor of New York
Tulsi Gabbard comes out and says yeah I
think that abortion should really not be
permitted in the third trimester a woman
should have the right to choose and I
will stand up and fight to protect the
right to do so off point for that I
think the third trimester unless a
woman's life or severe health
consequences is at risk then there
shouldn't be an abortion that their
trimester this is obvious this is common
sense you shouldn't kill babies that
obviously look like babies that are in
every way recognizable as babies I mean
people wouldn't have really disagreed
with this years ago but now for her to
that is radical I give her a lot of
credit for it because maybe it's not
going to do her favors in terms of
winning the nomination but it makes her
her own person and I hope it's really
what she believes now the thing you've
got to remember that while we're talking
about how great woke Tulsi Gabbard is is
she's still terrible she's still awful
she's not someone who should ever be the
president of the United States sometimes
conservatives fall into this trap we
fall into the strange new respect trap
the strange new respect trap is that you
you almost always see this on the left
which is that the minute that a
Republican starts criticizing other
Republicans or the minute that a
conservative starts criticizing other
conservatives the left will say Wow I
have a strange new respect for John
McCain see they hated him before when he
posed a threat to them but now that he's
being useful to them they they will
praise him oh yeah I called Bill Kristol
and Nazi war monger a few years ago but
now I have a strange new respect for
Bill Kristol and sometimes people on the
right can do this - we shouldn't fall
into that trap Tulsi Gabbard says yeah
we shouldn't kill babies like as they're
being born and we say wow great job
Tulsi oh my gosh wonderful yeah I think
a nation should have borders oh my god
it's stellar amazing no she's still a
radical left winger and she still
supports abortions up until the very end
you know up until in the third trimester
she still doesn't think that we should
do do anything seriously to reduce the
number of foreign nationals in our
country or seriously to to secure our
border she hasn't made any hard proposal
she's opposed the wall so she isn't a
great and she makes this clear when
she's talking about abortion because she
she kind of gives away the the whole
argument she doesn't speak about the
baby really she just talks about the
mother and if the baby's got to die the
baby's got to die what would you say to
the people that would say well wait a
minute the government's supposed to
protect life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness what about the life of the
fetus you're just that you're just
having that superseded you're having the
woman's rights to sue person did a woman
is a woman is the one who's got to live
with whatever decision that she makes
and that's where I draw the line and say
that
the government should not be in the
position of telling that woman what
choice she must make the woman is the
only one who's got to live if she kills
her child right if the mother doesn't
kill her child then both of them got to
live it's an amazing little Freudian
slip that tulsi gabbard has there look
yeah of course I support a mother's
right to kill her own child because the
mother is the one who's got to live with
it no she's she's only the only one
who's got to live with it if she kills
the other person involved even to use
the phrase who has to live with it what
you're saying is the baby doesn't have
to live with it because the baby doesn't
get to live because the baby is being
killed so yeah birds still you know
terrible candidates should never be
president but I do give her credit here
I give her credit it's worth watching
this whole interview I mean Dave does
such a good job with these but she came
out against identity politics
she said identity politics was a big
problem she came out against her rivals
speaking Spanish on the debate stage
kind of made fun of them for that I
think that's great I encourage a little
more diversity in the Democratic Party
certainly wouldn't be my preference to
have any of them in office but at least
you know if there's some debate it means
that there's an intellectual life there
they're not just hacks they're not just
living in a world disconnected from
reality
they're actually grappling with real
issues in real time and real people and
this is the the reality of it I mean
this is what what tulsi gabbard is
speaking to the vast majority of people
in this country oppose open borders they
think there should be some restrictions
on abortion they think people should
speak English when they're running for
president they don't like being pandered
to okay that's the vast majority of
people left right in the center the vast
majority of people in this country also
don't think Trump is Hitler I know that
the impeach Trump crowd they say that
Trump is Hitler most people don't think
that they don't think that I even about
most Republicans but Donald Trump is a
ælis celebrity
we've known him for 40 years he's been
in the tabloids since at least the 80s
people don't think that guy is Hitler
you're not fool
anybody and people don't like being lied
to look I know the Democratic Party is
always gonna try to lie to me or about
me the left is always gonna try to lie
to or about me but they're losing their
own supporters I think you know people
people might not like Donald Trump
people might prefer other candidates to
Donald Trump but they don't think he's
Hitler they don't think he's a Russian
stooge and if you're gonna be the hack
who keeps pushing that narrative you are
not gonna have any credibility you've
got to run unreality and if Democrats
can't get that message they're gonna
have a bad time in 2020 because in the
long run
reality wins and if Democrats don't get
that message then President Trump will
win re-election and what are the
Democrats going to do they're going to
pretend that they did win they're gonna
pretend the Trump didn't win they're
gonna pretend all of those things on the
fantasy pages of the New York Times
speaking of which this gets us to the
dumbest article on the internet today
which I have got to get to because this
was a very stiff competition today there
was an article in voxcom
about how we should lower the voting age
to zero that was out today there were a
lot of articles on the internet that
could have won but the one that takes
the cake was from the old rail ad the
New York Times this is the article what
draws atheists Jews and Catholics to a
Presbyterian Church that was the
headline on the Internet the headline in
the print edition was United by cause if
not by faith and this article is about a
church put it in quotes by in a sense as
a church in Manhattan it says it's a
Presbyterian Church that doesn't really
talk about God you don't really need to
even believe in God
much less Presbyterianism you just need
to believe in leftism and it's it's
amazing because it shows you the state
of religion today and the state of
politics today
politics is religion for the left and
real religion has been dismissed is the
article at Rutgers Presbyterian Church
in Manhattan social justice
environmental issues unite the
congregation there's Bible stuff too
that's good observant Presbyterians are
always part of gatherings at Rutgers
Presbyterian Church but much of the time
so were Roman Catholics and Jews as well
as a smattering of people who consider
themselves vaguely spiritual Valerie old
harsh McCarthy of course she's got a
hyphenated last-named and of course it
goes without saying who sat among the
congregation listening to a Sunday
sermon on the perils of genetically
modified vegetables is in fact an
atheist a few points of correction here
observant Catholics do not go to this
church because observant Catholics
cannot participate in other religious
practices they cannot go to other
churches that are not Catholic churches
so by definition if a Catholic is going
and participating in these services they
are not observing Catholics I I simply
don't have the expertise on Jews you'd
have to ask our yarmulke wearing
colleague over here but something tells
me a similar thing could be said there
as well these other congregations these
other denominations that are coming in
to this quote-unquote church are not
actually Catholics or actually
practicing Jews they are practicing a
religion but it's not the religion
they're pretending to practice I mean
imagine this is a Sunday sermon on the
perils of genetically modified
vegetables back in the old and bad days
we used to have sermons on the existence
of evil in the world on pride on the
virtues and on the vices on how we can
live in holiness on man's fallen nature
on our salvation on the profound and
eternal questions what is justice what
is fairness what is our life who am i
and what is my relation to the great I
am which is how God describes himself I
am that I am those were in the olden bad
stupid days you know those silly days
when people believed in religion now we
can talk about profound things like
genetically modified vegetables finally
now we could get to some real deep
conversation the article goes on
typically the connective tissue of any
congregation is an embrace
faith yet Rutgers Church a relatively
small church on the Upper West Side of
Manhattan has rejected that and not
quite they say they've rejected their
shared faith because some say they're
Jews some say they're Christians some
say they're atheist some say they do
have a shared faith we'll see what that
is sharing a belief in God and he got it
all isn't necessary
instead the community there has been
cobbled together by a different code of
convictions pulled in by social justice
efforts activism against climate change
meal programs for the homeless and a
task force to help refugee families they
are brought together by a shared faith
it's the shared faith in leftism what
you have seen we talked about how the
left goes in and hollows out
institutions from the inside so they go
into Harvard and they just like a bunch
of termites they hollow out the inside
of Harvard so from the outside it still
looks like Harvard but the inside it's
not it's been eaten away by the left
that's what they've done to this church
so when from the outside I guess it
looks like a church Presbyterian Church
but it's not and it's not the case that
they're not united by a shared faith
they are it's the shared faith in the
leftist politics they go on they say to
address shrinking congregations some
pastors are searching for new ways to
use their churches and redefine what
Fellowship means churches have the space
and the goodwill after all to commit to
community works social justice or arts
and educational products and opening
their doors in this way can bring in
those looking for more than a Bible
study class yeah it'll bring in people
explicitly who aren't looking for a
Bible study class they're they're trying
to address shrinking congregations talk
about mission drift they're just trying
to sell whatever they can they're trying
to redefine what Fellowship means but
churches are not there for fellowship
church is to worship God the mass is the
highest form of Prayer the mass existed
uninterrupted in an uninterrupted forum
for at least 15 centuries it then as
exists
in a few different forms or has had some
changes to it and some breakaways and
some dissent to it for another 500 years
after that that's what it's about it's
about worship you know this is for
Catholics it this is one of the big
problems we have with some of the
changes of the Second Vatican Council is
they took this beautiful mass and they
made it just about us so for instance in
the old days the priests used to face
away from everyone else in the church he
would face away because he's not there
to entertain us he's not there to do a
little soft-shoe and sing a little song
he's not there to make us a laugh or
clap he's there to lead us in the person
of Christ in worship he is there to lead
us to the sacrament we're actually doing
something but when the church just
becomes about you feeling good about
yourself well then you get to redefining
what fellowship means let me say why
don't we need all this god stuff when we
can just commit to community works or
arts or educational products or
educational projects rather the pastor
put that in quotes of this church says
you just welcome those who are seekers
seekers of what you know burglars are
seekers of jewels and money do you
welcome them you've got to be seeking
something to seek means you have an
object and in this case we're seeing
that in the traditional church versus
the Church of leftism
is we're seeing those who seek God
versus those who seek simply themselves
and their own little political
preferences so it goes on a large black
lives matter banner hangs from the front
of the church okay I know that's why if
you're going to have these political
statements why not all these different
political statements I don't don't all
lives matter to a church nearby or
colourful tibetan prayer flags although
it was a presbyterian church but the
Presbyterian Church has Tibetan prayer
flags because the Presbyterian Church
doesn't really believe in the
Presbyterian Church but if the
Presbyterian Church is going to have
Tibetan prayer flags why isn't it just a
Tibetan Church inside there are buttons
for worshipers to declare their gender
identity he him she her they them really
gives new meaning to the phrase
in the beginning God created man both
male and female he created them
I guess he created them as both male and
female all at once they're exactly the
same this is a contradiction if you're
gonna have 56 genders that is a
contradiction of the book of Genesis
during services worshipers recite
alternatives to the Lord's Prayer the
Lord's Prayer the one prayer that Jesus
actually gives himself verbatim they
recite alternatives to the Lord's Prayer
that use more inclusive language and
then you get to the punchline one of the
congregants there says I'm more into the
social aspect I care a lot I care about
a lot of the people and they care about
me me me me the Church of the self and
that is what you see of course the New
York Times loves this they love changing
the church which is essentially about
selflessness I wish to dissolve as st.
Paul said giving yourself away
committing yourself to God and
worshiping God to the Church of the self
we know from st. Andrew Breitbart
politics is down from culture culture is
down from religion no wonder the New
York Times as a cultural institution is
celebrating this major religious shift
because it as big big effects on our
politics politics where I think everyone
is regardless of what the New York Times
says regardless of what a few aging
hippies on the Upper West Side say I
think people are tired of being lied to
that's true in religion that's true in
culture that's true in politics that's
good news for us that's bad news for the
left that's our show no show tomorrow by
the way but we will be back Friday
because we have to cover that wonderful
Democratic presidential debate which
should be a lot of fun in the meantime
I'm Michael Mills is the Michael Doyle
show see them
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]